USA USA USA USA
I used to play soccer when I was a kid
so I've always been sort of an athletic
person but in the last couple of years
I've sort of just kind of left that died
a little bit I'd say I'm an active
person so equates to fit but athletic
very early on in life I realized that
I'm super ADHD and the only way to pose
as a normal human being was to exhaust
myself every day
so I would consider myself fairly fit
aside from the the violent overeating I
played sports through high school and I
consider myself very athletic so I had
to jump on the challenge welcome
everybody I'm coach jack I'm gonna be
teaching you some decathlon event let me
check out the equipment I've got some
bags for you oh yeah for you oh nice I
scared well let's go get the uniforms on
and take it a little more speed you're
dropping back on the pace come on
everyone together now push it three more
miles fit that's right I'm worried about
Kenny he's all smiles and bubble gum on
the outside but I know there's a warrior
lurking just under the surface see that
leg can get over the hurdle oh come on
Scott Reil I think wills gonna be a
strong competitor cuz he's a big man
yeah I think he's gonna kill me quick
feet quick feet
l-3 stuff we are at the track here we go
we've got a hundred meters sprint
we got hurdles to go chase we're gonna
long jump then we got the discus that's
a challenging one and the pole vault
runners cheer mark I was ready
oh yeah I didn't know I'd be that good
but I expected runners to your mark said
come on go go go come through that
hurdle there you go City we can win
that's why it's the coach cheering for
me to lose I just try to motivate come
on more speed more speed more speed
yeah I can't fake it anymore
Sierra turn it fling it
Oh father Josie a the kids are free
very impressive will I hate to admit
that because I was reading against him
the entire time
today was definitely a victory for me
made some friends one looked sexy the
pole vault was really really awesome
very victorious this experience showed
me that when you set your mind to do
something you probably will surprise
yourself with what you can accomplish I
wasn't the greatest but we got out of my
comfort zone I have some tan lines that
I'm not really happy about but it's cool
I think these people all have the
personality type that could be a great
effort you do need that I want to learn
it I want to do it correctly I'm going
to work at it until I own it